[Musique]
bonsoir vague félicitations donc à on
est heureux de vous écrire pour ce
centième numéro de votre édito et bercy
vous stéfanie lasnier pas voilà on est
là toujours là malgré le coc vide on se
penche donc sur un sujet restait jusqu'à
présent dans l'ombre de la campagne
présidentielle c'est le déficit
commercial de la france tout d'abord
avoir un commerce extérieur déficitaire
c'est c'est grave docteur pour rester
dans le sujet en fait ça dépend ça
dépend il ya des pays qui ont des
déficits conjoncturels certaines années
parfois c'est même provoqué par un choc
extérieur ce qui est effectivement
inquiétant dans le cas de la france
c'est que nous avons un déficit
maintenant pratiquement continu depuis
2003 donc ça va faire dix huit ans donc
ça c'est déjà un problème qui est
extrêmement important et qui démontre en
fait un problème de compétitivité
générale de l'économie française or il
faut savoir que le travailleur français
est l'un des plus productifs du monde il
est par exemple plus productif que son
confrère allemand donc le fait que l'on
est à la fois cette perte de
compétitivité et pourtant ce niveau de
productivité très haut ça pose un
véritable problème et on va voir que en
fait il ya des raisons mais l'une des
raisons ça pourrait bien être
l'introduction de l'euro en 2002 alors
je connais tout d'abord qu'en est-il un
premier à poser le problème exactement
de ce déficit commercial de la france
alors le déficit commercial de la france
en fait ils commencent on avait eu déjà
des années avec un déficit mais il
commence vraiment à devenir systématique
et là on le voit à partir de 2003 nous
aussi qui est extrêmement importante
c'est que c'est autour de la crise de
2008 que ce déficit prend vraiment c'est
cette dimension tout à fait historique
on est entre 2 et 3% du déficit ensuite
chose qui est aussi extrêmement
intéressante mais aussi très inquiétante
c'est que en 2020 l'année dernière alors
que pourtant l'économie elles avaient
reculé de 8% à cause de la crise
sanitaire bien et bien c'est là ont fait
l'un des pires chiffres du déficit
commercial moins 65 milliards d'euros
alors même que l'on est très en deçà de
notre pib autrement dit nous avons fait
à cette époque la fin l'année dernière
plus de 3% du déficit donc oui il ya
bien un problème extrêmement sérieux et
comment expliquer alors il ya plusieurs
explications qui sont possibles il ya
d'abord le fait que très clairement les
importations croire beaucoup plus vite
que nos exportations et ça on le voit à
partir de la fin des années 90 du début
des années 2000 le rythme de croissance
des importations est beaucoup plus
rapide que celui des exportations ça
c'est un premier point après on peut se
demander mais est-ce que c'est pas par
exemple la cause de la facture
énergétique par le saint le prix du
pétrole le prix du gaz sauf que les
années où le prix du pétrole et du gaz a
été particulièrement faible 2014 et 2015
même chose par exemple en 2020 on aurait
dû s'attendre à voir notre déficit
diminué eh bien pas du tout donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a un autre problème est ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que si on on
désagrège le déficit après par pays et
bien les deux pays
par rapport auquel nous avons le déficit
le plus important c'est la chine et
l'allemagne à eux deux ils représentent
47 milliards sur grosso modo 65 donc
saviez qu'il représente a vraiment un
montant extrêmement important par contre
le pays sur lequel nous avons notre
excédent le plus important passé la
grande bretagne dommage qu'il soit
qu'ils aient quitté l'union européenne
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que le déficit commercial de la
france il est essentiellement due aux
biens manufacturés et ça c'est vraiment
la trace de la désindustrialisation une
désindustrialisation qui se poursuit en
france depuis grosso modo les années 90
début 2000 et qui ne s'est jamais arrêté
est-ce qu'on n'a pas des points
d'excellence tout de même si bien sûr
bien sûr nous avons l'aéronautique nous
avons les industries du luxe nous avons
aussi l'agriculture mais il faut savoir
qu'une balance commerciale quand on l'a
désagrège en gérant grands blocs il y
avait bien il ya les services alors
traditionnellement et on le voit sur ce
graphique là la balance des services
elle a toujours été excédentaire ce
n'est pas un hasard c'est par exemple le
poids du tourisme en france on a eu orco
vise évidemment on avait eu pratiquement
100 millions de touristes par an
ce qui est important c'est que depuis
2010 à peu près et bien
l'importance de ce flux qui vient de la
balance des services n'arrive plus du
tout à compenser le déficit de la
balance des biens et donc ça veut bien
dire que c'est essentiellement sur les
biens manufacturés que se trouve
aujourd'hui le problème alors pourtant
jacques les autres pays de l'union
européenne il ce désastre est d' c'est
pas facile à dire les industriels disent
également à des degrés divers oui c'est
vrai mais ce que l'on constate aussi
c'est que le rythme de cette
désindustrialisation et bien il n'est
pas du tout le même en france de ce
qu'il est en allemagne ou de ce qu'il
est en italie prenons par exemple le cas
de l'allemagne de l'allemagne elle a eu
effectivement elle aussi un déficit de
la balance commerciale dans les années
1995 2000 qui était en partie d'ailleurs
liées à la réunification allemande et
puis après et on le voit là aussi sur le
graphique 1 c'est la gueule l'allemagne
et la courbe jaune est bien l'excédent
commercial explose il atteint entre 7 et
8% du pib alors que dans le même temps
et bien effectivement
le déficit commercial de la france
s'aggrave donc comme je les ai déjà dit
nous entrons déficits à partir de 2003
et on voit bien qu'il y a là un
véritable problème parce que l'allemagne
est notre premier partenaire faut jamais
l'oublier et comme nous sommes
d'ailleurs le premier partenaire de
l'allemagne aussi un nous sommes très
liés de ce point de vue là et donc on
voit bien qu'il y a un énorme problème
en termes de désindustrialisation
alors quelle est la cause de ce tournant
du débit de lait les années 2000 que
vous nous décrivez bon il ya de
nombreuses causes mais il ya une cause
que l'on peut maintenant vraiment isolé
c'est la question de l'euro vous savez
que l'euro ça
introduisent une certaine manière des
parités de change fixe entre les
différentes monnaies puisque nous avons
introduit l'euro en 1999
pour l'ensemble des calculs financiers
en 2002 pour les billets mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que tout
ce qui était produit en france étaient
transférés en euros au fameux taux de 6
francs 56 pour un euro dont le même
temps les inflations dans les différents
pays membres de la zone euro n'ont pas
convergé elles sont restées assez
largement divergentes ce qui veut dire
qu'on commençait à apparaître des effets
de sous-évaluation et de surévaluation
de l'économie qui sont extrêmement
importants alors la france on le voit là
elle est surévalué d'environ 11% après
on voyais à l'italie ou à l'espagne à
d'autres pays qui sont aussi surévaluée
mais l'allemagne et je reviens à ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure l'allemagne
notre premier client qui est aussi notre
premier fournisseur et bien elle elle
est sous-évalué 2 15% autrement dit il y
a un écart de 26 % et 26 %
c'est vraiment tout à fait énorme en
termes de commerce international entre
l'économie française et l'économie
allemande par ailleurs ça montre aussi
que l'économie française est bien
surévalué par rapport au reste du monde
puisque pour être non surévaluent il
faudrait qu'on soit au niveau zéro dans
la zone euro est bien là aussi alors ça
peut-être moins d'impact mais ça permet
de comprendre aussi pourquoi
eh bien la france accumule un tel
déficit commercial par par rapport à la
chine par exemple donc on voyait que la
question de l'euro est tout à fait
central alors vous nous parler de cette
catastrophe est due à leur os que ce
constat est partagé par la classe
politique m'a pas vraiment vraiment
regarder on a eu la semaine dernière le
fameux débat entre eric zemmour et bruno
le maire alors l'un l'autre ont reconnu
que la question du déficit l'obtient
était un problème bon oui ils n'ont
jamais évoqué le rosé vous pouvez
réécouter la vidéo jamais le mot euro
n'a été prononcée alors c'est quand même
tout à fait étonnant on a deux personnes
et en particulier le ministre de
l'économie et des finances quand même
qui connaît bien les dossiers qui
décrivent une situation mais qui sont
incapables d'expliquer d'où vient cette
situation et ça si vous voulez je crois
et je crains que ce soit bien le produit
de l'immense hypocrisie que l'on a sur
la question de l'euro dans la classe
politique française merci beaucoup
jacquet pour ce décryptage et à dans
deux semaines un pour les régions et
quoi puisque nous sommes en vacances la
semaine prochaine même si vous et bonne
100e encore m merci beaucoup